colombia observaba desde la distancia la
propagación de la pandemia en el mundo
hasta que el 6 de marzo de 2020 una
joven que regresaba de italia se
convirtió en la primera paciente de
coronavirus en el país vamos a aplicar
la declaratoria de emergencia sanitaria
desde entonces más de 23 millones de
personas se han contagiado de la
enfermedad y hay más de 60.000
fallecidos el estricto confinamiento que
inició a finales de marzo y se prolongó
durante casi seis meses uno de los más
largos de la región pasó factura a la
economía colombiana con altas tasas de
trabajo informal aumentando el desempleo
la pobreza y el cierre de miles de
empresas el pib colombiano cayó al 6 8%
el peor resultado de su historia la
crisis económica también dejó a cientos
de migrantes venezolanos en la calle
provocando una nueva crisis migratoria
agravada por el cierre de todas las
fronteras
miles trataron de regresar había su país
de origen colombia ha reportado dos
picos epidemiológicos
el primero el 19 de agosto de 2020
apenas unas semanas antes de que el
gobierno nacional iniciara la reapertura
económica a principios de septiembre y
el segundo brote el pasado 15 de enero
antes del inicio de la vacunación el 17
de febrero hay un leve atisbo de
esperanza a la población pese a la
criticada gestión de la vacunación del
presidente iván duque que pretende
inmunizar a 35 2 millones de colombianos
este año un ambicioso plan que nos
refleja la realidad hasta el momento las
autoridades han aplicado poco más de 200
mil dosis siendo el primer país de
américa en recibir las vacunas a través
del mecanismo kóvacs